in the course of the conversation the
pinners informed Caesar they had Toby's
DNA professionally analyzed in the lab
so my friend Toby is actually a Shetland
Sheepdog a collie a Labrador Retriever
and he's also Akita and they were bred
for hunting so we don't just have an
animal that is controlling the situation
we don't just have a dog that is the
pack leader we have a dog that has many
breeds and his practice in him all one
eret wow that's very powerful come on in
go on upstairs nice
nice nice no no no no so we're gonna do
it again
let me get Eric out no no
pretty fast you're getting really fast
all right let's do the whole interest
again if you don't mind
Eric remember the thought I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I know I know I know I
lost control the torch at that time is
to snap him out of it
no I honestly do not know what how to
get him out of it
Cesar I don't know how to snap him out
of it yes I think you're gonna need a
little more help than me just today see
right now I am able to to to influence
but then he goes okay so he's not just
going to level thank he goes beyond
level 10 I know that's that's the red
zone you know if he would go just to
level 10 we all could be doing the
exercise right now okay he definitely
needs a more consistent bootcamp so to
speak you know where he learns to be a
follower you know
aggression is not what happened right
away aggression is the outcome of
insecurity anxiety frustration tension
and we don't know was the source of his
aggression which that's why I want to
study him because right now he's
liability yeah you know I mean I wasn't
really surprised when Cesar mentioned
Toby needed to go to a center that he
needed more help and I think I even
mentioned it my wife Jackie and she
really didn't want to hear it at the
time of course because we really don't
want to let him go I thought in my heart
I guess I was hopeful that Cesar could
fix him here at home and that he could
give us the necessary tools to do it
ourselves
[Music]